you can't stop Colin Kaepernick's in the
past couple of weeks he's refused to
stand for the national anthem
in protest of racial injustice in this
country he since then been joined by
teammate Eric Reid Seattle Seahawks
Jeremy Lane and the National Women's
Soccer Leagues Megan Rapinoe the message
is that we have a lot of issues in this
country that we need to deal with we
have a lot of people that are oppressed
we have a lot of people that aren't
treated equally police brutality is a
huge thing that needs to be addressed
he's not just shedding light on police
brutality he's also speaking out against
widespread racism that continues to be
alive and well in our society and the
oppression he's talking about doesn't
end with how sports pro sports is most
definitely still a rich white man's club
sports teams are owned by incredibly
rich folks some of whom are worth
upwards of twenty two billion dollars
and nearly all of them are well white
that whiteness trickles down to
operations yes things have gotten better
in the last 50 years if you watch any
NFL or NBA game it's pretty clear that a
majority of players are people of color
but behind the fields and courts you'll
find a major lack of diversity there's
clearly more work that needs to be done
when it comes to hiring people of color
for president CEO general manager and
head coaching positions so how did we
even get here a lot of it goes back to
blatant segregation in the late 19th to
mid 20th century legal segregation
seeped into all aspects of American life
including sports where men of color were
not allowed to play in any of the major
sports leagues I have to mention here
that women of color have also had a long
history of being marginalized in
professional sports
now despite segregation communities of
color found ways to compete in sports at
historically black colleges and in their
own thriving sports leagues and
associations and black sports leagues
like the Negro League nurtured
pioneering athletes who later broke the
color line the NFL didn't fully
integrate until 1962 and the last team
to integrate was wait for it
the Washington Redskins can't make this
stuff up it's important to point out
that the NBA did find former LA Clippers
owner Donald sterling two point five
million dollars and been
for life from the NBA after racist
comments he made about black people were
leaked back in 2014 and that the NFL
didn't force the Rooney rule in 2003
this rule requires teams to interview at
least one minority when searching for a
head coach and senior operations
positions but these examples are
exceptions not the rule so a racist
history in the u.s. that included
legally shutting people of color out of
professional sports leagues continues to
have a major impact today Jackie
Robinson Muhammad Ali and the Williams
sisters are just a few of a long line of
athletes of color who's broken the color
line smashed stereotypes and inspired
generations but until there are more
people of color represented in
operations as head coaches and as owners
it's fair to say that racism will still
exist in pro sports and this is just one
example of the racial inequality that
Kaepernick is standing up against so the
question is what will it take for it to
end